holy crap reporting was amazing amazing
amazing games all at the same time yeah
but still amazed very frustrating I get
excited for Saturday game I am a then he
did a lesson the one o'clock sleep or
the four o'clock that 5:00 on at four
o'clock was annoying you you know what
I'm realizing you know there are not
many people doing what we're doing we're
just trying to watch every game at the
same time no and you know how I'm
figuring it out yeah there was a moment
when I would because I have redzone
audio right there's a moment where they
talked about Joe Philbin using two
challenges in the first minute and 30
right and I went on a Twitter and
Twitter exploded about that yeah and I'm
realizing everybody's just at home
watching red zone we're like I'm sitting
there being like second in short what
are the Ravens gonna do yeah most by
most people I know that's all they're
doing yeah like yeah like when red zone
would put on Packers Falcons I'm like
just get this off like who cares about
this yeah i don't watch red zone for one
second so i don't even know what i want
so that you understand what everyone
else is well but i do i see it on one of
the screens and it seems like that well
that's the world we live in you know
what else is a big thing in our world
yeah famously foot panels evil ball sims
I have bad news I love good news and
I've been right good news is is that
we're in the semi-finals
the team Odelle Rogers the good news is
is that we're going into Monday night
with a lead oh okay yeah the good news
is that juju Smith Schuster bless you
juju got us 29 Rogers got us 24 Tyreke
Hill at 18 the bad news is is that we're
only beating pigeon-toed freaks by 0.9
Oh
in essence he has Kyle Rudolph going
tonight
we need Kyle Rudolph to not get a single
catch yeah that's not happening do you
don't think so then I'm gonna
preemptively say yeah that it's been a
very good run I'm happy nothing tonight
oh is 0.9 lead we have a point 9 lead no
just one catch head jinto Frakes
congratulations because the the tight
ends will be a part of the game tonight
we're done yeah done ski unless Kyle
Rudolph got a zero
banged up blocking right they take them
out yeah that's our only chance so I'm
not I'm never gonna root for injury but
I'm just saying season season's probably
over because you know there's nothing
better than Odell then Odell Beckham
missing his first game all season in the
playoffs love that love that against the
sorry-ass Redskins when he's our
namesake of our team yes you've had like
300 yards your loyalty owed oh wow
take the picture down yeah get it out of
here okay here's what we're going to do
I was looking at the games and Josh said
I don't know how we're gonna touching
all this I said we're gonna play with a
shot clock this is the promise that
we're making for everyone today we are
gonna get through all of the games not
including Monday Night Football
obviously and you bet your ass we're
talking about Titans Jaguars Oh what in
fact you know what we're doing for
Titans Jaguars are we talking about I
just want to do a live breakdown of the
Derek Henry run okay
because I was one of the greatest runs
I've ever seen but anyway here's what
we're gonna do some of the games are
six-minute games okay some of the games
are three-minute games some of the games
are one-minute games no offense but some
of the games sucked and we don't want to
spend too much time I am gonna be
running the shot clock here is the order
that we're going to go in to make sure
that we're getting your team we're going
Rams Bears Patriots Dolphins gotcha
Steelers Raiders Ravens Chiefs because
apparently we talk too much mahomes and
we're gonna get very excited
Eagles Cowboys Saints Bucks Colts Texans
Jets Bills Panthers Browns Jags Titans
then the only three minute game is Jack
Giants Washington and in the one-minute
games no offense to everybody is Falcons
Packers Broncos Niners Lions Cardinals
penguins Chargers those are that's how
we're gonna break it down and if there's
a game where we're looking we go we need
one more minute yeah we can add a minute
to the shot okay are you ready I'm ready
what do you think sounds good does it or
you just patron I'm just patronizing you
why just cuz you're a host and let's go
start the show son of a [ __ ] okay first
game on the clock this timer begins now
bears Rams let me get the Sims overall
belief um do not be rushed without
racing yeah no III mean my overall
belief would be the Bears the elements
came into play right off the bat I think
that's the number one thing you do set
it through the betting show right I said
the one thing that came to my mind
cold-cold team from Hollywood talking
about a 58 degree day was nice to
prepare them for Chicago no negative
ghostrider it's 30 degrees colder in
Chicago that was yeah they were trying
to talk themselves and do it a little
bit certainly but the Bears I mean first
of all you saw the troubles from the
cold and people might go what was the
deal well this is the biggest thing I
mean first of all when you're not from
the cold you're used to being warm
feeling good you get hit things feel
different the balls slicker the ball is
harder that's why you see drops that's
why you see the ball slip out of Jared
Goff's hands at times Jared Goff threw
the ball horribly for the majority of
the night right right I know last two
weeks yeah he's averaging a hundred and
ninety-three yards a game one touchdown
five interception yeah but last night
was there was a few picks like the one
on the sideline to fuller yeah his eyes
were closed his eyes were closed well I
mean the interception backed up and I
can't remember which one I think it was
a Mook Umar when they were back in their
own end zone yes you know they might
been on the three or four yard line not
the safety but the interception I mean
he literally faded into Whitworth and
stepped on Whitworth there was no
pressure he went into him and then threw
the ball as he was backing up backwards
just down the field I don't know what he
was doing that was one of the shocking
moments of the night too man what Sean I
mean I know that Sean McVeigh was
falling on the swords by saying he put
his guys and bad for sure I I have two
things one I have a strategy for the
Rams a bunch of California bros throw in
the wetsuit and you'll be able to handle
the cold a little bit more under the
Jersey little wetsuit action surf a
little gnar you know it's interesting to
how we're gonna be serious I was only
kidding no I'm gonna be serious and like
when will one of these teams go on these
kind of weeks like they were gonna
prepare for Mexico City go we're gonna
go somewhere cold for the week in
practice so we're ready what
that happened I think that's kind of
like just one thing I thought I think
it's interesting you know like to think
okay you're the - my other my other
thing that I thought was right what I
saw a little bit in a lot of games
yesterday was a lot of not not blowing
the whistle playoff football is like
playoff basketball yeah sometimes let
them go yes exactly and I'm looking at
Brandon cooks and I'm looking at Robert
woods and I'm looking at Keenan Reynolds
and I'm seeing these guys getting pushed
around right and I'm going damn this is
what happened against Atlanta last year
yeah are you getting a little worried
about that I'm not worried about it you
know again first of all last week was a
week against Detroit Lions off a bye but
these are the things that really awesome
defensive teams do I mean Fangio is a
smart coach they have the personnel and
the scheme both to slow down a team like
the rims that's why I mean you pick the
Bears to win right I know all right well
that's why I picked the Bears to win I
mean not to say that I'm right or
anything but I just thought they could
get there with the front four they have
enough good cover guys they got good
safeties their coach doesn't live in
man-to-man no and he's smart about how
he plays his zones off that he blitzed
at the appropriate times you know and
when people hear me say that too and
they go what do you mean by the
appropriate times I mean that Fangio
blitzed when he felt like he had them in
a formation or a situation where he had
a beat on where they might like to throw
the ball and how their protection is
being protected right and he tried to
expose it off that he didn't overdo it
but the Bears were clearly the physical
more physical tougher football team
probably should have put that game away
even earlier true Brisky of course was
just as off as golf in the game in
general I'm seeing a lot of people in
all the podcast listening this morning
just surveying the scene the Bears are a
Super Bowl team the Bears are a Super
Bowl right
I believe the Bears can go into LA and
make that a close game yeah I don't
think the Bears can go into New Orleans
and meet the Saints I don't know about
that really I don't con it yeah I I
think the two wild-card teams right now
like Dallas right and there's gonna be
like the worst nightmare for these top
two seeds to come in town because Jared
Goff and Drew Brees are kind of smaller
and if you get a lot of pressure in
their face the whole system goes the
whole system
and those you know man just had a really
good take well no I mean I just think
the the Bears like let's talk about the
Saints right I can talk about that like
oh no don't go in the game
well I'm saying the Bears matching up
with the same okay yeah like how you're
trying to say it yes you know okay yeah
are you gonna you know I just break it
down you think the Saints are just gonna
smash the Bears in the run game
no I don't think so I just figured that
with like play action and enough of like
an Aleph
I just think that the Bears and all
their games that we're so excited about
the Vikings game this game the weather
and the elements in that Stadium have
played a huge role in all of them yes
sir and I think if we're going inside on
a fast track you know III don't think
the secondary or the Bears is that good
I don't know maybe I'm crazy no I mean
you're yeah I think it's pretty damn
good I do and I don't know you know I
guess the only thing I would say to that
and again it's not that your thoughts
wrong the Saints are certainly gonna be
a lot better there than they are
anywhere else but the Saints aren't like
the fastest team in the sport either
it's not like they're gonna go down
there and go oh no we got to play them
on field turf they're so fast how we can
up their kind of physical base - it's
different than years past with the
Saints all I'm saying is whoever's got
the first run by and they gotta have
Dallas or Chicago come into town you're
gonna go damn we better get ready for a
war here they both have what we look for
to be big off exactly right a front for
the game by themselves a smart defensive
coordinator we got ten seconds left
yeah sure Biscay you concerned or is he
still working no I'm not concerned I
mean he's coming off a shoulder injury
hasn't played in two weeks yes he missed
some throws there's no doubt about that
but as a whole I still think hey this is
a Bears team that's dangerous his
athletic ability keeps them dangerous
and also I'll say to this to the Rams
like this is one thing if you want to
take a bright spotlight from the Rams
I thought the Rams play defense the
proper way last night you know you heard
me say a little bit last week like they
do too much or they go for the kill too
much yeah they don't need to go crazy
they can play basic simple schemes they
have aggressive players like they got
players in the Aaron Donald who's gonna
shoot a gap he's not supposed to shoot
at times you're gonna be eaters right
I'll take two there's gonna take job
they don't need to have a defense that
goes take five chin
is in one play they don't need to do
that all right so six minutes works
that's good
yeah and I'll say one last parting note
yeah James Daniels hey yeah did a great
job Aaron is good too they are good okay
let's move on through and through next
game next game
Patriots dolphins I'm gonna go first
yeah go before we get to the Kenyan
Drake right and everyone's gonna say it
was a miracle it's not a miracle when
you've already hung 28 points on a team
yeah like that that's I don't want it to
get lost that like the Patriots defense
got messed up right I went through and
looked you had the brute the Brandon
Bolden a huge run the Bryce Butler huge
catch Frank Gore averaged almost eight
yards a carry and I looked it up the
Dolphins had seven plays of 20 or more
yards now as the shocker of the day I
mean they're on the ball at will Brady
did whatever they wanted but the
Dolphins were doing whatever they wanted
it yes the Patriots yes that would be
the two shocks from that game would be
this the amount of explosive plays that
the Dolphins got on offense never would
have thought that the Patriots pride
themselves on stuff like that exactly
they're kind of been don't break your
gonna kick a field goal and will score a
touchdown that and Brady [ __ ] his
pants look at the amount of situations
that they messed up in general I mean
just you know whether it was missed
field goals missed extra point no
timeout Brady taking a sack inside the
five with the clock running which like I
am dying to know - did they just think
Brady knew the situation and they didn't
um because when he got up he looked like
he was almost surprised like when he got
sacked
he got up like oh wait we have no
timeouts and I was why it's like no one
reminded him okay then they get the ball
in the second half and that's when they
went down and you have a chance to kick
the field oh they missed the field yeah
so they had the chance to have a
seven-game round right there the five
they were up that's 12 yeah handing
trick play never matters yeah right I
mean they just had chances to I guess
make the game uncomfortable for the
Dolphins
but the explosive plays on the Patriots
defense I'm with I never would have
thought that they had some very cool run
game design plays that I saw the one
that broke Frank Gore was cool but
little what we would call why wham play
is really a New England played to
Brandon Bolden side
I don't see where that comes in and
blocks it was kind of like the tight end
he does that and he blocks the deef they
let the defensive tackle go up field and
he goes oh I got him they're dead boom
when he gets side it gets ear hold yeah
but yeah I thought there was some
creative run designs there and Ryan
Tannehill made some big-time throws it's
it's very funny to me that one everyone
goes oh the Patriots they get to play
the bills and the Dolphins and the Jets
Tom Brady is 7 and 10 in Miami yeah 7
and 10 yeah I know
it's wild I mean the points still valid
they get to play the Dolphins the blue
yes yes you're right they've struggled
down there it's crazy that he's seven
intended so I'm watching the game next
to Omar Omar started Housel highlights
huge Miami fan right and I made the
Patriots a left go lock like an idiot
yeah and the whole game anytime
something happened we just curse at each
other right like it was just funny that
last play he lost his frickin mind
he's a very reasonable 24 year old he
definitely is but he just started
sprinting around the office and he ran
downstairs where most of the programmers
for Patriots fans it's amazing
unbelievable yes so the throw goes to
stills laterals to Parker throws it over
to to Mannion Drake
Kenyan Drake cuts acts like he's gonna
lateral it back which apparently there
was supposed to be someone there Ted
Larson lands a perfect seal block that
took out like two guys turns it upfield
and then Gronk stumbled on his own face
yes right and everyone's focusing on the
fact that he was in the game and not
Devin McCourty just one let's appreciate
that the Dolphins did this against the
Patriots and it was 69 yards and Gronk
didn't make the tackle and something
they win 69 which is perfect but what
sure what are you upset with with
Belichick do they really make a mistake
there well cuz everyone's looking back
and going was Tannehill really gonna
throw it 70 yards for you to knock it
down
I mean they have to throw it more than
70 so that's where I think they made the
mistake just to that part alone to I
would go if you're gonna have Gronkowski
back there not why not it be Josh Gordon
he can jump higher and he's faster I
know that for a fact so that would be my
other one yeah the fact that McCord II
was not on the field either that's
insane that's where I don't understand
I've been you
argue he's the fastest guy in their
defense so I guess yes they miss played
this situation you want to watch it
together I have yet to really watch it
you haven't owned the coaches coaches
though alright so we have a minute and
40 min 40 Wyatt and then we go so we're
gonna throw the shallow cross the little
hook and ladder it's the same damn thing
this is the same thing that Pittsburgh
did right right with the rate it's the
same play so now he's gonna pitch it I
really think the brilliance of the play
is once he gets to Drake
I think the brilliance of the play is
right here that Drake doesn't decide to
throw I'm saying he went he went biggest
Seki I think that's supposed to be the
next guy he was supposed to throw do he
was oh buyer his I think his recognition
to go you know I got a little lane here
and before everybody wants to jump on
Stephon Gilmore his job is not to run
over here guess what no one's jumping
okay they're good everybody is looking
at Gronk and going eh why was he on the
field right he holy [ __ ] he's slowed
alright I heard a lot of people jumping
on stuff yesterday but either way that
was unbelievable when he cuts it up and
then yes Gronk is acceleration is not
his name of his game every joint on
Gronk's body has a hinge like every me
every elf I feel like a man I feel like
he's wearing rollerblades
yeah well rollerblade blockers on his
wrist the other thing I'd like to say
yeah why the hell is this Kenyan Drake's
first catch of the game I don't know if
there is not a Miami reporter that looks
at Adam GaSe and goes why are you still
giving the ball to Frank Gore and
Brandon Bolden and you see what Kenyan
Drake is capable of yeah every play he's
every game he's the one making the
40-yard touchdown and he doesn't touch
the ball I was his first catch of the
game I know that's insane now there's
something there that's a trust issue or
whatever it is but either way that game
was mind-blowing the way it's so
frustrating the way New England blew
opportunities hey you know I know
even when they were I mean of course I
bet that was my bed of the week oh yes
it well who neighbor up 2721 and they
had the ball there in the red area I was
like it's over it's over they're gonna
go up the widgetts here when this by 20
and this is not even to be close but
you know Adam GaSe good good job by him
again his team he I can never say this
about every case his team always plays
tough and that's where I respect that
I'm guess they are a gritty Bunch and
Ryan Tannehill probably doesn't get the
credit he deserves either and I'd like
to keep a tracker before I move on him
yeah all the games in which the field
sucked ass number one I was gaming about
a hot five spot of yeah hell not care
about the place right i watch people
pulling up chunks of turf it's
embarrassing let's move on yeah
we're gonna keep luck because it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous all right
next game speaking of ridiculous
Steelers Raiders yeah first thing I'd
like to say there's a five hundred and
ten dollar swing in our bets and not
only did the Raiders cover right they
one and two all the Raiders fans that
reached out and said you believed in us
you bet I did
never even doubted it never doubted it I
will say this thank God Josh Dobbs
played for five drives let's start there
Sims Ben Roethlisberger comes in the end
of the game tries to be the savior
throws a touchdown pass to juju that was
kind of scary looks up if they Lord says
thank you the Lord and then it comes out
afterwards that Tomlin said he could
have come in drives before yeah go Tom
and did his best and not throw him under
the bus there you're angry well yeah
it's just aim I'm angry from a personal
level to a guy who you can't call out to
your teammates two weeks ago and tell
everybody you're the captain and you can
call them out and then get hurt they
miss a field goal get the ball back
drive your team down score a touchdown
before the half going to halftime not be
on the sidelines to start the half then
jog out wear a hat and do nothing until
the game finally goes oh we're down they
need me now now let me go back out there
you know that's just to me is a BS move
I don't know what any other what I said
it's not what a captain does I know that
when you're the highest-paid player on
your football team and again hey listen
I have sympathy for guys that are
injured of course my career was ruined
by injury so I understand that but if
you can play late in the
first half and then he showed us he
could play late in the second half then
what was the deal all the third and half
way through the fourth quarter in a game
where it was the biggest game of the
season yeah you don't have James Connor
you played awesome in the first half I
mean just move the ball it will
basically because they are the Raiders
defense there's no doubt and so I don't
know to be my issue there more than
anything I'm just a real crappy move I
felt like by Denver I wrote on my notes
Big Ben is back lol yeah cuz it just it
felt staged
everybody knew I had friends texting me
around the NFL going I guarantee he
comes back once the Raiders go up
I guarantee mean it didn't matter where
I was anybody that knows anything about
Ben knows this is the kind of guy he is
a little bit he is more of one of the
mores diva franchise quarterbacks and
you know me I'm an apologist for Ben I
think Ben's one of the all-time greats
but it's these little things right here
that never give him the benefit of the
doubt because of the way he handled this
situation and I'm hearing a lot of
people saying they lost to the Raiders
they lost to the Raiders how do you lose
to the Raiders those people you haven't
been paying attention about this offense
the last few weeks Derek Carr I think
has been playing quietly very good
football these last few weeks he did
drop 33 against the Chiefs he did not
play bad against the Ravens even though
they put up 17 we see how good the
Ravens defense is and that throat a
Roberts deep towards the end of that
game in the fourth quarter it was
unbelievable to set the carrier
touchdown and I get that the field goal
kicker missed but I think that you
wouldn't have been in that situation Ben
if you would have just played the game
and established a lead instead of
playing with with you danger like this
no but I mean they had they had him they
had I mean Pitts Oakland couldn't maybe
ball court a half you know what I mean
yeah but there was an all Jared cook and
the Pittsburgh figured it out but Josh
Dobbs had an untimely interception as a
red zone and then they didn't convert
the fourth and one and they didn't
convert the fourth one right those are
just keep giving them like that's life
in the NFL how many times it isn't
amazing how much we've said that lately
like the NFL is crazy it's so close if
you don't put a team away
it's just a matter of time before the
other team gets some momentum on their
side to make a play to come back or
we're gonna remain a New Orleans a
second like they could've put that game
out in the second quarter right but I
look at the Steelers and everyone's like
they're at risk of not making the play
what do you think well number one yeah I
did pick the Ravens to win the division
so I would love to have that break right
but as I said to you before yeah
remember when the Steelers were 1 2 & 1
yeah they had just lost to the Ravens
and everybody said Mike Tomlin's lose in
the locker room and they didn't win 1 or
2 or 3 or 5 they won 6 in a row and now
we're sitting here and they've lost
three in a row right I would not be
surprised if the Steelers beat the
Patriots at home go to the Saints beat
the Saints in New Orleans and then beat
the Bengals to win out the rest of the
year and go Tay one baby would yeah and
it's not shocking to me because now look
the raiders did take advantage of John
Bostick with Jared Cook brought to you
right but I will say that the Steelers
can match up with any team in the NFL
they can and they just don't give a
maximum effort all the time and I like
Mike Tomlin teams with the back against
the wall yeah area I don't like him with
expectations I like them with impending
doom right I don't want to talk about
him being fired you tell me that's gonna
happen yeah cuz I think he's gonna go in
the office and go maybe if you're a
legendary quarterback didn't take
himself out for - well I think that has
to be part of the conversation sometimes
mike tomlin like he's not picking these
guys in the draft
you know something he's managing them
he's not so sometimes we look at these
people that I think I'm the Steelers
amigo they're renegades and they act
crazy and you know again he's draft he's
not buying the recipe he's not buying
the groceries the groceries to to cook
the food there so at times he has to
deal with what he has and make best with
it but yeah that was a big loss for them
I mean really I mean crushing and here
we are they're gonna be fighting for
their lives I don't know did you see the
video of Jon Gruden running over to the
Raiders fans after the games and high
five and I do not know it's just the
best yeah it's just John he was pumped
and good for him he keeps fighting I'll
give him that Ennis
there you go yeah I'm just gonna wrap it
up in a season in which many people are
talking about guys that are no longer on
your team right Kaleo mack Amari Cooper
you were awesome yesterday by the way
exactly it's winds like that where you
go maybe we are going in the right
direction right but I just I want to
give a little bit of credit to Derek
Carr because I think a lot of people are
[ __ ] on him and I think he's played
pretty well the last few weeks yes with
an injured offensive line has no real
like Jeff Roberts has argued like Jared
Cook is his number one receiver right
now yeah and his backfield is Doug
Martin who played well last week against
the chiefs and we can't helped it as
running backs fumble three times actly
you know all right I'm gonna set the
timer what do you know Ravens Chiefs who
where I mean I loved both sides of the
ball in this game yes it was the perfect
football the perfect football game it
was awesome I mean the game came down to
everything we wanted the mahomes with
the ball down seven against the great
Ravens defense so Josh and I were
talking the entire game right our dream
scenario was that the Chiefs drives down
drive down kick the field goal to win
the Raiders cover in a very tough game
in which the raven and it happened just
like we hoped right like you guys nailed
it you you and Papa Phil and myself like
we all nailed it yeah yeah it felt good
it did feel good it was a great game to
watch of course I mean the Ravens as we
talked about leading up to the game they
have the formula to beat that football
team we know that hey I don't know what
else you could say just long story short
the Ravens got the game exactly where
they wanted to their money their team is
built around their defense and what was
it a fourth and what nine nine yes and
they had my home screen right worth nine
we talked about that during the week to
when he goes right you're in deep
trouble you're in trouble when he goes
right he's just the plays not over
because the whole field still available
when he goes right but that was insane
that fourth and nine 129 left on his own
40 39 yards downfield to an injured
Tyree kill yeah Sammy Watkins didn't
play Kareem hunt doesn't exist all he
has is Kelsey a limping
Tyree kill right Sammy Watson's hasn't
played in forever and I'm still doing
this unbelievable I know he went over
300 yards
I mean to me that was the MVP clinching
I think he put the nail in the coffin
I think he's have to throw like three
interceptions in the last three games
here but like I don't think let's talk
about the few plays he made in this game
yeah the fourth and nine roll out thrown
right in a degree of difficulty for
someone that's played put it into like
person like we're talking five people in
the history of the sport could have done
it I mean I'm being nice with five I
don't even know I'm saying that just as
a prize you're gonna say Elway and Roger
exactly I'm gonna say Brett Favre okay
mahomes in my home's so that's four I'm
not sure if I maybe there's not five I
mean right now those are the four that
come off to my head to be able to run in
a full sprint in the way which he was
running 2017 Carson Wentz any Hey well I
mean Carson is similar to that Carson's
I'm not gonna put his arm quite in their
class it's a it's close yeah because I
don't think Carson or Andrew Luck would
have outrun those guys know I don't know
if they can contort their body and
really go you know again the amazing
thing is he was by the right sideline
the ball was completed on the left hash
that's where how far is that I mean how
is a sideline to an opposite hash you
know like I don't know exactly know but
I'm gonna say roughly from the sideline
of the hash is probably around 33 yards
something like that the far hash right
so he's doing now it's long 40-something
down thirty right Pythagorean theorem I
don't know which squared I think it's
around the 50s yeah it's probably around
there and I don't even know if it's his
most impressive play of the game no I
mean you mean his [ __ ] magic Johnson
no-look pass have you ever heard an old
pass I have but not to that degree how
about the degree of difficulty there so
my mean I threw one in a preseason game
against the Tennessee Titans and Jeff
Fisher okay and I Paul Hawk that Jeff
Paul Hackett was my quarterback coach
and Nathaniel Hackett's father right and
I was scrambling to my left and I was
kind of talking the line of scrimmage
and I knew I had a guy on my left right
at the one-yard line and I just acted
like I was gonna throw the ball down the
middle
because I was like ooh if I can just get
a little space here I'll throw to him
and I kind of looked straight ahead and
I threw it out of the side of my kind of
the side of my eye but I was kind of
peeking as I did it yeah mahomes did it
like legit no look hitting a guy in
shape I mean to defend right insanity in
sanity and the play that no one's
talking about is this side are and laser
beam then he threw to the sidelines
amidst all these defenders and the ball
stayed at like 5 feet above the ground
and did not rise and did not fall that
would be the definition of a piss
missile right there I mean yes he can
drive the ball through targets right
some quarterbacks hit the target and the
ball has to banana in there and you go
oh baby he hit the target he can hit the
target and the ball will continue to
drive right through it
I mean that's where he is as special as
it gets
he really is do you have more confidence
in the Chiefs now um because you have
been doubting them lately
the Chiefs I mean they're not like my
favorite the style of play which they
play is so rare I know exactly what your
theory is and to be that puts themselves
into situations in which they need
miracles but you're at a point now where
you've seen this guy make so many
miracles that you can't bet against them
anymore no you think he put so much
pressure on you you can handle it and he
can handle it and with the guy ability
of just a few guys like Kelsey Hill and
him and then Reed's aggressive play
calling the pressure they put on you is
enormous through the football game but
if Tyree kills hurt I don't think
they're there so that'll be a game
that'll really change there was a Holy
Office of philosophy yes we have 30
seconds left oh my heart was really good
and I'm formally putting in a request
I'm going to do one minute after this
because we have a lot more talked about
I thought Lamarr played well I thought
the Ravens offense like there was a DRI
that stood out to me in the third
quarter yeah it was a 14-play right
seven minute drive from yeah that ended
in a touchdown that was Gus Edwards
Kenneth Dixon Lamarr yeah
Gus Edwards Kenneth Dixon passed to mark
engines right and it was beautiful it
was gorgeous what do you thing about the
race
now I mean I the Ravens got in another
minute just like we were saying the last
few weeks the Ravens got their formula
this is the type of team this is the
type of style of football they want to
play and I think that pretty much proved
yesterday that they can play with
anybody in the AFC it doesn't matter
anymore you did this to the Saints oh
right play with anybody in the NFL thank
you they get in the playoffs they're
gonna be a handful to deal with because
of all the things they can do and they
just need they just need consistency and
a few throws a game from the pocket from
Lamar Jackson and we saw that I thought
he played pretty well for the most I
thought he threw behind a lot of the
times he did I felt like but I will also
say that there's a ton of people coming
out and say that they got jobs like I do
not think that was offensive pass
interference on Crabtree oh that was
rough people are saying that Willie
Snead a hundred percent got P ID on that
last-ditch effort by RG three right on
Harbaugh came out and said I want to
talk about the refs yeah you need to but
that's the other theme in this week
right refs were not good was not every
number games there I was questioning it
I want to give a shout out to Justin
Houston right two huge plays at the end
of the game to seal that one for the
Chiefs yeah but they're gonna be good
and I look at the rest of the Ravens
schedule and I go home against Tampa W
yeah they end the year home against the
Browns gonna be tough but I think they
got that right and then in between at
chargers they're in the driver's seat
yeah they should finish the season
strong I think the Ravens are in the
playoffs yeah the Steelers keep messing
up they might win that division they
might but they would be my pick to at
least be the six seed you're right I
would go with that
through the team I'd won in there I did
me too you're exactly right I always
root for the best six teams that's what
I want exactly I don't give a damn who
you are I want to see the best teams in
the playoffs not only for the
entertainment purposes but you are gonna
get to whoever the best team is most
likely when you have those type of
formulas and you're gonna really see who
actually deserves to win the NFL
championship and yes I do think that the
Baltimore Ravens are certainly one of
the best six teams in the and the AFC
and that is a perfect segue to our next
six minute game yeah Eagles Cowboys yeah
I was watching that game and I said the
better team is the Cowboys so the
football person inside of me is saying
they should win because it's better for
them to be a three or four seed but I'm
a knight
killing me yeah that's the end of the
Eagles season I don't want to hear about
all these opportunities I know that the
succeed is open if Minnesota loses to
see I don't want to hear about it
the Eagles are not one of the best six
teams in the NFC they're just not no
even if the refs were abysmal
I missed the opening kickoff fumble
right
did you see it I did yes I don't I'm not
got a good enough look at it to go was
there a clear recovery call those things
yes there was okay so the ball clear
fumble right and it went into a pile of
four players all four of the players
were Eagles so I don't think it matters
if it's clear right
if camus grugier-hill is fighting with
Brandon Graham I don't care they're both
Eagles right
that's insane cuz that would have
completely swung the momentum of Sharon
Wright and the offensive pass
interference on Ghadir
are you kidding yeah that was a stupid
that was a horrible call that was an
80-yard time it wasn't even close right
and then think about Jeff heathen
initiated the contact the Eagles offense
was able to move if that's a touchdown
when Dallas drives down the field again
maybe the Eagles get the ball back right
but instead they had to use all that
time on that drive yeah it was a killer
man it was a killer it just sucks when
you lose and you still want to blame the
refs a little well yeah that always will
always drive you crazy but it's easier
to lose when you know you're not the
better team on the field and they were
not that I know that I mean the fact
that I read an article from Peter King
that said the Saints spent all week
targeting Sydney Jones because of leg
injury right and then I watch jim
schwartz put Sydney Jones on an island
with a Mari Cooper with no safety help
mm-hmm deep I can't like anymore bowels
B Busby was the one in the long one
Avante boss like like that's insane
that's insane it's the only opportunity
the Cowboys have for a long touchdown
you let them have it every time well
yeah in those situations you got a
double or do something to just go what
you got to prove us he'll throw to
somebody else because all he was gonna
do yesterday was throw to two guys I'm
re Cooper and if he wasn't open he's
gonna check it down to his ego yes it's
really like charm oh yeah maybe a little
sprinkle here and there but I mean I
guess what the first thing I would say
for your Eagles that was their year
right there it was really the year
Michael Bennett plays I'm inspire
defense though they let too many big
plays you couldn't run the ball you know
we're all gonna blame Carson once I go
on the regional sports networks and talk
there it's always like there everybody
thinks it's Carson Wentz yeah is a
Carson as a Carson Carson saves your
team he's the only reason you're in
games like that some of the throws he
makes are just they're mind-boggling I
need to do this for Philadelphia yeah
people are saying Mike Gro has to go
yeah people are saying that Carson Wentz
is a problem when you look at their
offense right how much is play calling
how much is the scheme how much is the
offensive lineman how much is a lack of
a deep threat how would you diagnose it
yeah I mean I think it's all of it first
of all the one thing I can tell you for
sure is it's not Carson Wentz and if it
was Carson Wentz I would sit here and
tell you he playing like [ __ ] so don't
think I'm playing favorites with anybody
I don't like him that much he hasn't
sent me a Christmas card I don't give a
damn so the the thing is yes the play
calling is needs to be more imaginative
the run game has never taken off this
year I mean again I go back to that all
the time with going last year you were
one of the best running teams in
football this year you're one of the 10
worst it's because they lost a giant
Blount or is it hard rules of running
different calls from running partly that
you've had a jumbled some people on the
offensive line so continuity hasn't
always been there but yes I think more
or not at the end of the day it's the
fact of the not proper run calls not
running downhill as much not always
being as patient with it as they should
be and then yes not having the guy that
could at least scare you a little bit
down the field nobody's scared of you
guys so everybody squats on everything I
mean you see Carson Wentz throws back
shoulders and it's just got a bill he's
gonna throw right
Cowboys yeah you believe they're a legit
threat home I ran away because my my
argument would be right now yeah they've
done so much damage recently at home
yeah and they've had like three of their
last four games and I know and I want to
see can they get that much pressure can
dak be that comfortable sure to the
Superdome or if they go to LA yeah now
the Superdome I do believe so they'll be
on that turf the there are a team where
I look at and go grass I think will slow
them down in LA a little bit that will
play to not to their favor they go to
the Superdome I think they're gonna be
fine there
yeah I do I may have found their formula
from a few years ago when they were 13
and three Cooper's special we're seeing
the Cooper we saw the first two years
and they're not making most game
interview I don't even know who that is
I know he's there with Erin Andrews
and he's elaborating and he's he's going
listen man I run a lot of slants but you
know what and I'm like I haven't like
that's the most words in that sentence
fragment that I've heard you said yeah
he's a new man new man
I know credible I know he's totally
change his personality I love the he
hasn't talked to his mom mama got him
right and he realized like what am I
being so angry about I'm playing
football and they're paying me a whole
lot of money and the freakin Cowboys
traded for me and they want me and they
think I'm good
he doesn't need to run a lot of routes
if he runs a slant the go and then like
instead right or the post corner as we
would say good luck I mean that you when
you're Michael gallops got some burner
right so if you have that skill set to
run those routes and threaten people
with the go route of course then you
have the ability to catch the slant and
run away from people you know they don't
need to do much they don't they don't
need a complicated formula they have it
right now their defense is Suffolk it's
unbelievable their defense they should
have I mean they should have won that
game by at least I know I'll have a
better answer for everybody on Thursday
on the film breakdown but they should
have won that game by at least 10 points
they were clearly the better team on the
field dak Prescott interception driving
down oh my gosh that was horrible right
okay then they throw it he throws the I
mean the wide receivers wide open on the
interception when they're backed up and
kori Graham gets it and the Cowboys
missed a field goal right Cowboys missed
a field goal so there was so many
opportunities again for them to put the
game away and luckily they they made a
few plays at the end to put the Eagles
Eagles defense I don't want to say they
were uninspired they had a number of
goal line stands yeah Michael Bennett
played really well I thought Fletcher
Cox was in the backfield the entire time
yeah this secondary izi is a mess it's a
mess it's a bunch of young guys it's all
over the place right but I look at the
Cowboys and I have 40 seconds left dak
Prescott and Wentz I mean excuse me dak
Prescott and Jason Garrett I felt like
Jerry Jones
watch that game and is like I'm gonna
give them matching for your extensions I
think there's a chance I mean dak
Prescott has definitely gone so bad for
three quarters though Chris well so bad
it wasn't so bad I mean I don't I didn't
look at it and go oh my gosh it was
horrible I mean you know they're never
gonna just be like this he's the best
quarterback enough yeah he's about
middle-of-the-road
I I understand that if they can get dak
for the cheap it'll be great yes
dak has gone through a stretch though
where I will say this he's thrown the
ball about as good as I've seen him
throw it through any stretch you know
has he made some mistakes yes I mean the
interception like the one we were
talking about when they were a red zone
fringe and going down there and he's got
the crossing ground he's got to see the
backside corner there you just can't do
that those are little mistakes that
you'd like to have back but I do think
it's trending in the right direction I'm
gonna be the counterpoint to the Cowboys
as I go into the next game in the last
five games their five-game winning
streak they've beaten the Eagles twice
yeah Eagles defense is not good they're
secondary stink they've beaten the
Falcons Washington and the Saints yeah
all of those defenses are struggling
yeah the Saints aren't but it was at
home yeah but I hear you hey listen they
all I could do is play the teams in
their schedule but that is that is a
just thought I understand that but
either way their defense is real and
they have enough of a formula on offense
now to just give them somewhat of a
semantical advantage they have what all
teams that want to win the Super Bowl
need to have yeah an identity yeah yeah
alright next game is gonna be the team
that we've been kind of referencing a
lot Saints bucks mm-hmm unbelievable
that we said the Patriots and Saints for
some reason struggle with these teams
they absolutely did
Saints down 14 to 3 drew Brees playing
like doo doo fumbling screen
interceptions can't get have his own way
and then they rip off 25 straight points
catapulted by Taysom Hill blocking a
punt and and getting them ready to go
what did you think of that game overall
Oh
again another that means not to sound
like I mean a voice recorder here but
another opportunity for a team to put a
put another team deep in the hole I mean
it's a missed field goal okay in the
first half by Cannizzaro was a chip shot
okay then they get the breeze fumble in
the third quarter and set themselves up
again for a chip shot field goal to go
up 17 2 3 yeah
they don't get it yeah Saints get the
ball they go three and out they punt it
yep
Bucs go three and out Bock putt like all
I kept thinking about was Ray Lewis and
momentum is real that's all I kept
thinking about him is that's all I
thought about the whole day because that
changed everything from that point on
the game was never yesterday was over
two on field goals right they couldn't
they couldn't build the league and they
were easy once I mean they were like so
those again you know listen you want to
miss one of those sure okay I get it
this day and age in the NFL the one
where they were up 14 to 3 and had a
chance to make it 17 to 3 that was a
huge turning point in the game because
of course the block punt came right
after that yes they blocked the punt
they scored the touchdown
it's 14 11 Tampa goes 3 and out they get
the short field again these Saints off
of the backed up punt
they score another touchdown it's 1814
and all of a sudden the game was over I
mean that was it
did you remember Saints should be proud
of their defense Sammy they shut him out
kept him in the game quarters was the
only reason I mean stopped him on some
short yardage situations where they were
down there close and what was the play I
was gonna talk about I can't remember
what the hell it is I wrote it down hold
on but either way their defense played
really well that's a game cam Jordan has
two sacks it was it was so sloppy it was
another field that was disgusting yep I
mean you guys are playing on spray paint
do you remember though the Saints coming
down and having trouble in Tampa when
you were there - yeah I do I can't say
that like even I remember I mean Drew
Brees his first game there the year I
lost my spleen he they came down there
with Reggie Bush and company and I mean
they won and we weren't good that year
but I mean they played ugly
I mean drew through it like crap I mean
they didn't have anything good going for
them
game they just beat us cuz we weren't
playing worth a damn but yes it's it's
odd how that seems to be like it's one
of those trap spots for them I think the
Saints were the big winners yesterday of
almost every team in the NFL other than
the Chiefs yeah she's pretty much
guaranteed home-field advantage
throughout the playoffs with the
Patriots and the Steelers and all these
teams losing but with the Rams losing on
Sunday night and the Saints saving their
season pretty much huge now they have
the advantage and they play two of their
last three games against the Panthers
yeah who are in complete free fall right
and the Saints have owned the last five
years yeah and their one game against
the Steelers is at home so I think the
Saints were the big winner yesterday and
I think that look they played they
played this was the toughest stretch of
their schedule they had think about the
teams they've played we talked about at
Baltimore at Minnesota home against the
Rams at the bengals was there one
reprieve home against the Eagles home
against the Falcons and then it went
three road games in a row
at Cowboys at Bucs and then the next
games at Panthers right that's a
tireless stretch that is they get
through that they get a bye I still
believe the Saints are the best team in
the NFC I still think they're going to
the Super Bowl yeah and I think that
they're a team that the only thing I
they're like the Patriots I'm afraid if
they're not at home now it looks like
they don't have to worry about yeah it
doesn't seem like they're gonna have to
worry about it they they certainly have
hit a lull you know and you every great
team hits that during the year where
it's good they're hitting it now yeah
exactly right and get it out of their
system maybe they can right the ship a
little here the last few weeks just to
get it going again and then get
recharged for that by week like you're
saying but you know every great team
goes through those periods I don't care
how good you are the good thing is they
found a way to win the game yesterday
more or less and it was the special
teams and Taysom Hill that really kind
of jump-started the effort to get them
back in and I think to this point to
like last thing because I know we're
gonna move on here is I think pretty
much ends the Drew Brees MVP
conversation why well I mean you know
why no well I mean you know hey it just
they didn't eat him at all - really
wouldn't an underwhelming day right I
mean the reason they were down was
because of him whether it's the fumbles
or the interception on the screen pass
whatever it may be but just mahomes for
formants alone I mean mahomes separated
himself from the pack yesterday right I
mean girl he's out of the convo Jared
Goff I mean Phillip Rivers maybe he's
the next guy in line right now I don't
know charger stink stink bro no all
right so that's good with that game we I
don't reset his left I know but I think
it was I think it was a very clutch win
for the Saints and it also showed you in
a mirror of the reality of their
situation and that the whole team needs
to be clicking and unless he gets that
ball out quickly to Kamara and quickly
to Thomas and lets them create it's a
whole nother story I will be that is
definitely a film I will have everybody
ready for on Thursday morning when we
get after that this was my second game
that I had queued up in the screen so
you start the clock right now Colts
Texans Colts capped the upset in Houston
breaking the Texans nine-game winning
streak
I told you I told you the Colts were
gonna be we're gonna be tough for the
Texans it every time I looked up the
Colts defense was very impressive yeah
they were attacking deshaun Watson but
really it's Andrew Luck man Andrew Luck
is just special and T Y Hilton 9 for 199
tu I Alton tears up the Texans
unbelievable he does well ok so the
first point to your to what you're
saying with deshaun Watson and
everything they're like III think again
that's something that we need to talk
about because I know I've talked about
it we've talked about this that
yesterday was the perfect example when
they can't run the ball
their pass offense lacks creativity as
well mmm
it's very lot like the rims exactly it's
very well it's very just all about the
big pass play
it's OD Andre Hopkins is one on one or
Demaryius time ember I've said the last
Yuke's
they missed some of those underneath New
England rose things like on first down
they can get them six yards to keep it
in second and four when they don't have
the run game cooking their past game
schematics are pretty simple they are
simple New England that's what they are
and you could see that the Colts were
all over some of their past game stuff
once and once they shut down the run
game they were in a good spot and
there was nobody to worry about other
than the deshaun Watson scrambling now
to the other side of the ball I mean
you're right bid this equip tonight the
Colts have found the kryptonite to the
NFC AFC South they found they beat every
team they've every week they got five
incredible hulks on the offensive line
to deal with the four incredible hulks
that are on every AFC South defensive
line here is T Y Hilton's performances
against the Texans I'm gonna just gonna
go from yesterday backwards yesterday
nine for 199 the other game this year
four for 115 then he had a three for 14
and then before that five for 175 and
two touchdowns nine for 115 in a
touchdown
you go back to 2014 he at a 223 yard
game like it's a ridiculous assortment
of performances by tyo yes it is but it
doesn't make me less confident the
Texans it doesn't no that's that's one
of the few teams in the sport that has
an offensive line that can go Oh screw
you Jadeveon Clowney and JJ wide and
Whitney merciless we don't need to help
our old line against you guys we can
just go five on four and we'll be feel
fine and what really to me as I watch
the game and again this would be another
great breakdown and you know I know
we've talked about this too with the
Texans the Texans are creative on the
back end and they go for the kill a
little bit at times a little too much of
time so where it leaves them open to let
up big plays like we've talked about
before and as I watch the game and you
watch it I just went oh the Colts are
just gonna they Colts just decided the
hell it said hell with it we're gonna
spread the field yes and we're gonna if
they want to blitz and Andrew will get
it out but if they just want to rush for
Andrews gonna sit there and be patient
and that's what he was he had the time
to let down the field routes develop and
of course he's one of the greatest down
the field throwers we've seen in
football over the last ten years he's
special that way and that's where that's
where they won the football game the
there's a weakness of the Houston Texans
defense at all it is they lack one cover
guy they need one more cover guy against
the high octane offenses just for the
talk the reasons we're talking about if
they're pass rush isn't getting there
that day they're just they're there one
guy short in my opinion
but uh man aintry looks really good
you know what's incredible to me I just
looked up yeah the Colts defense is 11th
overall yeah they're ninth in rushing
and they're 15th in passing hmm and I'm
looking at this team and I'm seeing
Darius Leonard and we've talked about
Marcus hunt and but it's this ragtag
group of guys so no real lashes not
Andrew Luck in the nobodies yeah they're
making it happen yeah I mean the Texans
struggled to get to 21 yeah they were at
14 for most of the game now their
defensive line has a little blend of
everything the athletic linebackers that
we talked about they play a defense that
doesn't really put pressure on their
corners and they don't have good corners
they kind of they kind of play that you
know Seattle pres you know cover three
press bail but they are a team in the
offseason they get a pass rusher and get
one more cover corner that they can put
on an island and you let ever fluss have
a little you know freedom with some guys
within his system to go yeah I can do
this with this guy then let everybody
else do whatever yeah I mean why is it
that some games i watch the texans and i
go their offensive line moves people and
then sometimes I watch and I see them
getting destroyed yeah I I don't know if
I have a definitive answer for you
there's beat up on weaker people yes
they just like they were moving the
Browns wherever they wave to east on the
weak that would be one of my things for
sure yes they feast on the weak and the
Colts have sneaky depth and sneaky
versatility along their d line how about
vanity Ares white beard how about is
what how long was his freakin field well
I think you need to finish that before
that's I mean that's insane he's 54
years old you know uh you know the Santa
Claus yeah when Tim Allen becomes Santa
Claus and like a beard grows you look
like a beard just like popped up on his
face right he looks so old I know well
what is he 44 45 I mean I had seen a lot
of 44 year olds that don't have a beard
like that yeah what's it just all white
it's got that God look that in shape God
look he's a hall-of-famer no but I wrote
so many times luck as a baller like the
scramble throat at ey Hilton in the
third that set up the pass down the left
sideline
yeah that's insane where he stepped up
it was like
- he told me that one yeah that was
insane Andrew Luck out deshaun Watson
deshaun Watson where deshaun Watson
please how dare you steal my lines but
you're right he did III find the Colts
and I'm jumping on your bandwagon there
they're very refreshing team to watch
because they're gonna either pound you
with Mack or they're gonna spread you
out they're gonna have nah heme Hinds
and they have all these no-name
receivers other than T Y and Eric Ebron
yeah but all of the things flow and I
will say this to wrap it up watching
Frank Reich on the sidelines
I went [ __ ] yeah I know why
can't he be the guy yeah he was the guy
he was the guy little did we know he was
the guy alright we're gonna spend
surprisingly six minutes on jets bills
I'll have to go the full time I don't
know how much of this game you saw I we
watch this because I really wanted to
get a firm grasp on it early on Josh
Allen was doing whatever he wanted yeah
this he now has in these last three
games more rushing yards than Mike Vick
had in three rush three games in a row
in his career right and what was I
saying last week it's not sustainable or
he's incredible I just don't understand
that nobody's really made it a big deal
of it like if Michael Vick did this this
would be on the cover this would be the
start of every highlight show and the
planet but with Josh Al and they go why
isn't he throwing the ball more or he's
not accurate I don't know it's it's all
because of the the the early narrative
on them now it's like that that's where
it drives me crazy this damn business
I work narrative was that we wanted to
hate on them so they don't want to
really give him credit for sick crap
he's no I mean Josh Allen gets in the
open field unlike a 40 yard run I get
really nervous that he's gonna run over
people like it's it looks like another
life form yeah it really is incredible
yeah now he did have some bad
interceptions where he kind of forced it
up he did have a rollout where he kind
of threw it down the sideline I almost
made an incredible play the rollout
interception was dumb as hell but that's
just dumb and that's something he'll
have to get you know get out of his
system when I rewatched it I was like
this kid just has so much belief in his
arm that he just thinks if I don't if it
doesn't get like somebody either
overthrow them and I'll get there right
Robert Foster is a baller he is
he's a legit wide receiver for the
Buffalo Bills yeah but look the Bills
had a field goal blocked at the end of
the half yeah um they had that they
missed another 50 or 40-yard field goal
at the end right before had this game
they had the game the entire time had
the control let up the big kick return
by the Jets right that set up the short
field for the right because the Jets had
done nothing they just said good kick
returns throughout the game I there's at
least two I could remember and they also
fumbled one of the kick returns to start
the second half
oh that's right but then Sammy darn
Samedi that play was great if you guys
haven't seen it fourth quarter down
seven Sam darn old rolls right under
pressure spins runs back to the left and
then throws sort of off-balance - Robbie
Anderson who's covered for the touchdown
to tie the game and now I'm reading
articles today saying that was his
defining rookie year moment yeah I mean
either that or I thought another nice
play was just his his throw down the
right sideline - Robbie Anderson that
was perfectly placed right shoulder
right that was beautiful exactly right
yeah that was hey Sam Darnell you know
again he showed his moxie his ability to
also scramble move around make plays
that way that's the thing he's been
great at when he's played this year that
was you know it's a good win for Todd
Bowles and the Jets they go up there and
pull that off I do think they were
outplayed yes yes but either way they
capitalized on on the the misgivings of
the Bills and made something happen
we're hanging out with Sam tonight we're
doing something with Santa Claus and
when I saw him get hurt in the second
quarter I was like first quarter I was
like and there goes Josh he was walking
off with his shoe off I was like oh man
we're screwed for tomorrow anything else
with that game that sticks out to you
let me see I don't think so
let me just see I got another note or
two that I just want to look at it's one
of those games where when you watch the
replay on YouTube it's like and then the
putt and then a punt and then a punt and
then they punt yeah you know yes I don't
know if there's anything else that
jumped out to me more than not I mean
other than just the two rookie
quarterbacks you know I mean both looked
really good I'm amazed by some of the
things Josh Allen can do I don't think
you know and hey maybe I'm biased I get
that but I think the physical ability
and some of the things he does
is pretty off the charts but no I think
that's all that's all there is to it I
mean we got to give our the kid Roberts
who had all those kick returns I mean he
was one of the saviors of the day all
right so here's the Josh Allen statistic
yeah with 87 yards in the first half
today Josh Allen has 321 over the past
three games the most by a quarterback in
the Super Bowl era mike vick had 294 in
2006 so that's not just rookie year vick
right that's any yeah that's 2006 where
they broke out the read option on me and
the Tampa Bay Bucs and we didn't know
what the hell to do and I'll say this
for people that are saying like Josh
Allen isn't where he needs to be with
throwing the football for him to put
this stuff on tape and to be able to do
this with Robert Foster and Zay Jones as
his wanted for season with no tight end
I say Mackenzie's pretty yes and an aged
LeSean McCoy
and an old and broken-down offensive
line if you put good pieces around him
and he continues to learn the playbook I
am fine with a guy that's athletically
superior to everybody else in the field
every time Josh Allen takes the field
he's the best athlete in the field
pretty much that's the guy I want as my
quarterback I mean he's the one that I
look at and you go out of all these
rookie quarterbacks who could be Patrick
mahomes next year I go Josh Allen and I
and trust me I think Baker Mayfield is
awesome and I know we're gonna talk
about that in a minute so but yes Allen
and Baker Mayfield are the two rookies
that excite me the most going forward
for the rest of their careers because
they just have some elite traits that
you know the other quarterbacks have
some but these these two have have a few
more than the others it's almost like
you saw the rundown but you did but I
didn't because I never share it Panthers
Browns and let's just start off with the
plays that everybody saw Baker make yeah
the deep touchdown the deep pass - what
do you know brashaad Perryman 460 yards
in the air
unbelievable but the touchdown - Jarvis
Landry yes what a freakin dime I mean
insane I mean he the ball really pops
out of his head
hops out of his hand hop it's a special
arm I mean let alone that or what was
the other deep one that maybe that's the
Bouchard Parham you know
thinking I mean he threw one of those
ones when they were backed up and he
changed the field of the I was that was
from his 20 and he got caught he threw
that see he threw that ball like 63
yards in the air yeah first thing I'll
say awful play-action both of those
plays you know again there's no better
way to create big plays off then awful
play-action pass when I heard in the
Rams yeah that no quarterback plays
under center more than Jared Goff I went
that's solely because the play-action a
and then they lead the league in
play-action right that's where I I've
been telling you know you've heard me
say the crossers or people should call
them back-to-back we just go play action
cross play actually cross props to
Freddie kitchens yeah because it's I
think he's only been sacked three times
since Freddie kitchens took over yeah
and the offense has been explosive down
the field shots but that run to Jarvis
Landry with him kind of coming around
the jet sweep they did it twice both
turning touchdowns yeah I was like
50-yard right the Browns are clicking
yes they are and they're they're fun but
I would hear more about Baker yeah I
mean Baker I just think you know there's
two people that jump out to me about the
Cleveland Browns more than anything
right now
it's Baker and their second round picnic
job Nick Chavez I mean hey listen I was
a Sony Michelle Phan coming out but I'm
right now yeah I mean you were right I
mean if you ask me who I could take
right now I would go I take Nick Chubb
Nick Chubb does it's like four extra
yards every kind heed I mean there's
times in that game yesterday where I was
like man they haven't they need to run
him more what are they doing like why
isn't he not getting the ball a little
bit more but hey they got something good
work in there in Cleveland got a few
stars on defense got an old-line got
Baker got Jarvis got Nick Chubb you know
they get they got Callaway they get
another receiver or maybe out of the mix
here next year another corner watch out
for the Browns I mean then they got it
all and there's a reason Bruce Arians
said I'm only coming back for the brown
eye yeah right I mean there's a lot of
positives to that job overall
that was another game where you picked
the Panthers I picked the Browns yeah
yeah I guess I got our law all the close
games wrong right yep I picked the
Panthers to win 24 to 20 yeah you want
to talk about that side of the ball with
hams yeah sure I'm hearing things that
he's hurt yeah and that he can't throw
the ball deep like are you seeing that I
mean I think some of his throws
look awkward with the way he's going
about it like even the the what was that
the the fourth and goal throw he had
where he missed high he's missed a lot
of balls high the last two was the same
play against the Troy it was very
similar about that yeah a two-point
conversion I know there was a few other
throws too throughout the game where you
know the interception that was the same
thing that was a high ball down down the
middle of the field I does a ball go
high well if you're injured I would
think it's just he's trying to keep his
arm tight he's protecting it a little
bit he doesn't want to just totally let
it go and be a slingshot so he's kind of
keeping it fixated and there's one harsh
injector yeah he's kind of just getting
stuck underneath it a little bit I did
an Instagram life for a bleacher report
just now and yeah they're saying is Ron
Rivera gonna be gone what do you think I
don't think that's fair to say that at
this point I think Ron Rivera's earned
himself one down here definitely I mean
hey they are on a bad streak there's no
doubt about that
and I know all things always go back to
the head coach but manna they messed up
some resin tires the reason I get rid of
round rivera is for having Brady Hoke on
staff at all like when I heard he was
let go I was like why is Brady Hulk in
the NFL that's crazy yeah the we just
talked about Kenan Christian McCaffrey
yeah is having an an Offensive Player of
the Year candidate season he's not gonna
win it right but man is that kid special
he's awesome that would be one of the
turning points of the game I would talk
about when they didn't score a touchdown
and they were at 1st and goal from the 9
yard line
ok they ran the ball on first down for 6
yards with Christian McCaffrey right off
the right guard or right taxes when they
made it 22 17 with a field goal
yeah because I wrote down this line I
ran tons of place inside the 10 ahead to
settle for a field I think this is the
one where they came away with nothing
right didn't they go for it
I'm pretty sure maybe I'm wrong because
he missed a fourth down throw right oh
that's the end of the end of the game
that's where I mean oh ok what McCaffrey
for 6 yards yeah then I believe they
gave the ball to DJ more on second down
so are you going to get to the playlist
and pick it up
yeah on second down I believe they gave
the ball to DJ more third down they
decided to throw it and of course fourth
down he had it first down run McCaffrey
four six
second down DJ more four no game
incomplete to Samuel incomplete to right
yeah
to me I just they were reaching it they
were ripping off some runs with
Christian McCaffrey at that point let
him go in and score at least one more
time
second down you just ripped off six
yards go again let's see what he's got
I mean that would be my only take there
or maybe you just smash Cam Newton over
the middle but either way the game was
there for them to be had once again and
they just didn't make the plays in the
big moments and the Browns didn't and
that's all there is to it and that's why
the Panthers are a deep crap Baker may
feel amazing you really love the kid I
do I really do
I mean um yeah I just think he's got
he's got a special arm and he has a
special feel for the game he's he's a
natural he really is even his little
play-action fake and it held it behind
he's got it he's got that good attitude
to it yeah and nobody is questioning his
comments about a huge accident now huh
no you know what the bellman is
questioning him putting a flag in the
middle of Ohio State's meal how dare he
want to win since Hugh Jackson when did
you Jackson get fired which game was
that do you remember no he got fired
after not the Chiefs game no no I'll
tell you right now let me say just not
after the Chargers they went down the
Bucs he didn't get fired thereafter the
Steelers without was yes it was they
lose to the Chiefs but played well and
then they've won three out of four after
that Chiefs game mmm-hmm okay you know
what Hugh Jackson's record is in
Cincinnati since he got there how that
they haven't won yet
throwing for yeah yeah come on man
Baker's the guy
that's crazy Baker is the guy and I'm
just excited because I've been so tired
of seeing that Jersey with all the
Browns names on it I don't know I'm not
even rooting for the Browns I'm just
tired of hearing that whole thing yeah
you know yeah Baker Baker's a baller no
he's a baller he's got to go and like I
said him an Allen of the guys that
excite me more than any last six minute
game oh gosh six minute abe's Jaguars
Titans you need six-minute abs I need
something you need seven
I'm at that's what we're gonna do eight
minutes uh Jaguars Titans yeah before we
get to the run okay which if you want to
pull it up that would be a manly thing I
have it on film I don't think I don't
know that one yeah yeah yeah
the Titans just own the Jaguars yeah
they really do do we just chalk this up
as the Titans just seemed to have the
Jaguars number or do we get excited
about the Titans again only to get
dismayed one week later I don't know if
I'm getting excited about the Titans I
mean I'm more disappointed with the Jags
you know all their talk and shenanigans
just to get physically run over the way
they did that was embarrassing
I would also like to say it's
embarrassing that they fired their
offensive coordinator Nathaniel hacker
that was a great performance by the
offense man they did a lot of things
I'll take those predictable plays we
were talking about when the Daniel
Hackett that seemed to be always open
any day of the week so anybody want to
talk about that but yeah either way
hey the offense was stagnant we know
that Leonard fournette it's got to stop
just running into people's asses okay I
was texting you right and I was like I
was like the one thing I'm not doing at
the goal line
yeah is running behind Eric flowers and
yet they kept doing it at two or three
times I know I'm like you got AJ can you
got Parnell yeah I didn't realize was
one of the larger human beings in my
life and we're running behind Eric
flowers yeah why I know I don't know why
either are you gonna watch it yeah let's
watch it it's amazing it's the greatest
greatest ninety nine yard run I've ever
seen ever and what's so funny is all the
older people and social media are like
and here's the clip of Tony Dorsett and
I'm like did Tony Dorsett take four
souls on his way to the endzone no no
this is the greatest cool thing about
the Cowboys one though is they only had
ten people on offense and they still
went for an end I knew or touched into
you who's it against the Minnesota
Vikings on Monday Night Football also
had like all the I thought it was
primetime all right here we go
so 725 in the second quarter I mean
first thing is hyda the jaguars d-line
just get collapsed okay that's the first
thing I watch Tate like is that young
rock way they're all 3rds
then he goes out and he takes a J booyah
in the face and he falls and then Jacobs
comes that rookie from Wisconsin
linebacker was right and now miles jack
should be embarrassed why is he the one
that should be embarrassed
he's too physically free key to be put
on her highlight reel like that
come on I why are they all trying to
tackle them around the shoulder exactly
left go why didn't miles jack this man
has the smallest legs ever I mean chop
his legs out right there I just thought
also just to go back to the start the
jump over the line right there you got
to the outside and then poof AJ what
does AJ Bowie thinking I don't know
either again go low because you're not
gonna win the benchpress contest against
Derek Henry look he's a beast
he is a freak show you know Jacksonville
I have a theory about this it's okay I'm
just gonna go into my theory to here
first of all they're not a team that's
about size right
they're a team that's built on more
speed than anything on the defensive
side of the ball they play with emotion
and just ferociousness and they get out
there on the field they try to overwhelm
you what they're you know with that
ferociousness and team speed where they
overwhelm teams at time but when they
give their all effort like they did last
week against the Colts leading up to the
game I do think it's hard for them to
muster up that same type of energy four
days later I mean I felt like tell van
Smith looked like he lost 10 pounds
between Sunday and Thursday
I mean tell Vincent look at him in the
middle there look he gets block he can't
even get off the block look there's
Derek Henry's 20 yards down the field
he's still being plucked he's still he
got blocked all the way down in the 20
and then somebody threw him down man but
yeah that was that was a the bullies got
Boise so what was your theory there my
theory is that there's such a they're a
smaller team especially on defense
they're about speed ferociousness flying
around the field right when you have to
play a game like they did on Sunday
against the Colts where they had to make
the stop every play had to be all about
them it's hard to get yourself up to
that same point four days later and deal
with that ad alone that yes you're not a
big team I'm not giving them an excuse
I'm just saying that's what can happen
to these type of football my theory is
this for the last two three seasons that
Jaguars have gone on the field and
they've been bigger stronger faster and
there are certain people that are bigger
and stronger and faster than them yeah
and there's not a lot of them and Derek
Henry symbolized that in one shirt right
no one on the Jaguars defense is bigger
than Derek Henry no one on the Jaguars
teeth there are some guys that are
faster but they don't have his size and
he's just mean man and so if you're
gonna constantly go we're just gonna be
bigger than you you're just not gonna be
bigger than him
no and I love his stiff little braids in
the back it's like a little tail but
that was one it's also a thing where a
lot of people have said man Derek
Henry's a disappointment for the rest of
his career you're not allowed to talk
crap about Derek Henry because that's
one of the greatest runs I've ever said
it and it's never taken away from him
and how are they not unleashing him
successfully every game yeah I know
well hey he's gotta learn to run a
little harder between the tackles too at
times and be just a little more
aggressive that way I think that's one
aspect of his game is running on jet
sweeps apparently stiff arm I get that
they find
have you ever been stiff-armed I don't
know I can't recall one of the happening
to me really not that I played a whole
lot of defense in my career so I don't
remember any bad ones
I just am fascinated the fact that just
putting your arm out can stop another
NFL player oh I can do it definitely
yeah I mean I could I threw some stiff
arms here or there I mean it's an
effective thing for guys that especially
like me who weren't get outrun anybody
or do you long arms and a little
strength you know you hit somebody in
the head you hit somebody in the face I
don't care who they are it's gonna stop
but is the key like extending right
beforehand yeah you're holding it out
now yeah you got a jab the head you got
to get them to where they're not
expecting it stops their momentum and
then they can't know what they're
grabbing on to all the way they're
grabbing for anything great a stiff arm
you've seen in person ooh great a stiff
arm I've seen in person I feel like all
staad had a few where I was just like
whoa that guy just got thrown into the
ground not just to the ground like he
went into the ground
he was pretty awesome everybody's got
their kryptonite in the NFL though every
Jaguars had the Titans they do that's
there
kryptonite I mean you're just you're at
one point during the year you're gonna
meet that one team where you go yeah our
record might be better or we might be
better at this but they match up with
you in certain areas to make your team
look less than alright well now we're
going to the only three minute game Oh
Giants Washington uh and it's three
minutes because we need to have the
discussion I agree with you thank you
sake one Berkeley is the best running
back in the NFL
yes I don't think it's close I think
that it's Girly's there yeah Zeke is
there right but I think it's like well
yeah I mean nobody does more with less
on a weekly basis I qui see I mean I
know though the long touchdown run
everyone's gonna go oh it was so special
that he ran for 78 yards first of all
what special tire defense look like they
were not moving exactly like guys like
Josh Norman and haha couldn't Dick's who
don't have a ball in their hand never
gained ground and the guy that outweighs
both of them by 15 to 20 to maybe 30
pounds it was the fastest run documented
the season was it yeah I didn't know
that
didn't hit 22 miles an hour but it was
the fastest one documented this Wow
according to next-gen Stan yeah I mean
our stats or the next generation he's
unreal he's unreal but then he had a few
other ones where he likes he likes tops
and he like comes back across the only
running back that I see jump land and
still not get tackled by that first guy
and he's just punching Washington guys
in the face like 170 with no Odell he
was doing whatever he wanted did
whatever he wanted
I mean hey did he had a catch a
one-handed catch of the game yeah on the
left sideline is yeah I know he's sick
he made the best receiving catch in the
game he's he's overtaking Odell as the
prime awesomeness of the New York Giants
right now but if you were the giant yeah
knowing everything you know though yeah
would you have taken out Josh Allen or
sake one ooh
because Baker wasn't available yeah so
if you were the Giants now yeah you love
Josh Allen yeah love sake and everything
I know is the Giants wanted Josh Allen
that's who they were going it was
between Josh Allen and se Kwang Barclay
and so who would you take now
that is really tough so I put 3 minutes
on the clock gosh I mean I I probably
would have got on Josh Ellen if I was
gonna be totally honest with you and try
not to be a prisoner of the moment right
now I'm we're talking say Quan and
awesomeness back at that time no no or
even right now everything you know now
Todd don't qualify this I'm still gonna
take Josh Alan yeah I probably we're
gonna feel guilty about it but it's okay
so yeah it is it's a really tough one
because say Quan is transcendent
transcend it and he is he's special
right but I know what you're thinking
Rhys I know what I'm thinking yeah and
that win yesterday yeah Eli's coming
back oh he's coming back and we get to
do this whole thing one more time Eli
like get out of here but they're
salvaging it enough to where I mean come
on salvage whatever he done told
everybody that the second half of the
schedule was light and that Eli was
gonna look good and then they're gonna
get caught up in all this nonsense again
it's Sanchez decided to help him out I
mean that was just Josh Johnson first
pic of the AFL getting in there in place
was just disgusting it really was I mean
they should be embarrassed oh by the way
you know what else was the deal with
that field right disgusting disgusting
Washington is talk about an owner that
really doesn't care about anything well
I mean the stadium's not full I mean
it's just a bad look altogether right
there and DC they need to get the hell
out of that during Virginia they need to
get closer to Washington DC again
they're out in the middle of nowhere all
right one o'clock games don't have a ton
on any of these because they didn't
really matter first one
Falcons Packers the one thing I'm gonna
say jeer about Mike McCarthy coming to
the team midweek and he went up there
and he thanked everybody right they up
and they gave him a standing ovation and
everybody was crying right a closure I
love that yeah that's cool yeah everyone
was saying you need to give him the full
year yeah I love that they brought him
back but you know they got a falcons are
a mess and the Packers get the win
packed yeah I mean with nothing changed
offensively from what I saw just so
everybody if everybody's wondering if
there was anything different there no it
was still Rogers making great throws to
guys that were covered Roger scrambling
I mean he red led the team in rushing
until late
in the football game when they were way
up ahead or him throwing balls
aggressively down the field that create
pass interferences or s or something
like that but yeah the Falcons you know
yeah they they should be ashamed of
themselves I mean especially their
offensive performance and what they did
after the first tribe they did nothing
for the rest of the day Matt and Ryan
was uninspiring it was a horrible
interception pick-six that hero and
really did nothing you want to talk
about garbage time stats I mean what
what were his stats in the fourth
quarter I'm just gonna say this yeah I
don't think Steve Sarkisian is coming
back neck is in deep trouble last five
games 2016-17 1916 yeah that's not
acceptable with that group no yeah and
but the thing is there's a lot of teams
the NFL can blame injuries and I get it
but they're not really one of them they
lost their whole defense no I'm least
they're all both starting guards yeah
but my think would be more of a marching
a lot of teams the NFL that manage just
because you lost two guys in your
offense doesn't mean you're offensive
fall apart when you have that kind of
talent next game Broncos Niners clock
has started Kittel 210 receiving yards
in the first half zero receiving yards
in the sign I mean to me it looked like
Jacksonville Jaguars 49ers from last
year Shanahan found he cracked the code
on the run game bootleg combination on
the Denver Broncos and he exposed
something I'll have answers for you on
the Thursday podcast but yes there was a
con they're making you say well there
was something there schematically
because there was just so many throws
where he was wide open I mean just going
across the field off of a boot or the
long touchdown pass he lined up at
fullback they did a play-action fake the
linebackers are pointing to him as he's
running by like you got him I got him
you got him and then it's a touchdown so
he found something schematically within
them like the Jets - did the Broncos how
we talking about that remember where I
said they were having a show so cover
the tight end and he also be responsive
with the be gap I am interested just to
see that that point and this the reason
I picked the Niners was because Denver's
offense without Emanuel Sanders yeah I
couldn't even get Phillip Lindsey going
yeah no they couldn't do it no but the
Broncos I didn't think we're ever going
to be a real contender for playoffs
right and that really silly that kind of
ended it that was another game we
disagreed on yeah
because I picked the Broncos at a close
one right yeah yep unfortunate fortunate
Lions Cardinals one-minute game I'm
gonna say that the story for me is that
the Lions came out after the game and
said we're playing indoors and the field
was disgusting how is that possible so
much so that Patricia said that
practicing outdoors in the snow yeah
prepared them for playing in Arizona
what was the deal with the field so I
don't even know we're not they tried to
bring it outside to dry it off and it
was like I'm wet mess nothing like
playing indoors on a crappy field how is
that possible on our field that goes
outside and outsiders I mean what did
they do it's the desert so how did it
get wet I don't know man and if it was
rainin why didn't we roll it back in the
stadium and close the roof I'm happy I
did not spend a lot of time watching
this game I saw Darius I got the Pick
six
yeah but literally the headline in the
Detroit Free Press was Detroit looks
awful and win and I was like wow that
sounds great yeah Josh Rosen did nothing
I got nothing to say either other than I
saw the Darius Leigh interception I'm
trying to think of any other points of
the game that I saw that jumped out to
me and I don't think there really was I
can promise you I don't think I wasted
more than just a few highlights here
people messaging me that Zack center
should be getting carries over
LeGarrette Blount and welcome to
watching LeGarrette Blount in the second
half of the season that's typically
alikum yeah yeah I mean you know
LeGarrette Blount is not the guy you
want
carrying the ball throughout the game
he's gonna leave yards in the field you
want him in there and just a certain
power certain you know situations that's
that's when he's at his best and the
final one minute game of the week
Bengals Chargers how dare you give only
one minute to the second-best record in
the AFC they look like and yet like [ __ ]
everyone that's going on TV right now
I'm talking about how the Chargers are
the second best team you guys are out of
your mind if they don't get Melvin
Gordon back soon this offense is a mess
26 points against the Bengals oh this is
the Chargers big slash and blow from
Keenan Allen slash and play get to the
red zone crap crap crap field goal it's
every dry yeah
no believe me someone that's bet on them
a bunch yeah they're not doing anything
yeah no it was it certainly I mean I'll
say this much to me this would be the
game that I I know I didn't bet much
here cuz I was expecting a little let
down from the Chargers I was just from
the simple vac their defense is not
great for demons sake Jeff Driskel
looked pretty good no and Joe Mixon ran
the ball all over them anywhere he was
right I'm gonna put one more minute on
the clock I underestimated them yeah
well and and you know we've talked about
it over the last few weeks so the
Chargers they lack big people I mean
they really only play like one
linebacker sometimes it's three safeties
and one linebacker in the game so that
got exposed yes and you know the Bengals
defense just personnel-wise because they
got the three corners on the outside
that at least gave them a fighting
chance to slow down you know the
Chargers attack but again human emotions
okay this they came off a gigantic win
sure against the Steelers and it's
sandwiched in between the biggest game
of the year for them in four days I
don't know so it happens no I mean I
feel you there's things to be concerned
about but I'm not gonna sit here and go
oh my gosh they suck they're ten and
three but they suck and that was one bad
performance against the Bengals I'm not
ready to do that
well the Chargers beat the Patriots yeah
I'm asking you what the charges were in
the playoffs so the Chargers can beat
the Patriots I mean if you're making me
pick that I would say no I would
probably take the Patriots but I don't
think it's like if we're like I'm not
gonna sit here and go oh yeah I'm
willing to bet fast like do you think
the Chargers could stop the Ravens
rushing attack no they would have a hard
time Thursday is gonna be awesome yeah I
could talk all this [ __ ] then Thursday
the Chargers what's the thing the thing
about the Ravens rushing attack word
like the Chargers would match up better
with that the Chargers are decent on the
cover on the outside so they could put
all their eggs into stopping the run if
they have a few good drives and then all
of a sudden long- out the Chargers
probably cuz I lost a bet yeah guess so
you're all about bet you're the betting
guy now just to update that AFC right
now for the six seed Baltimore Indy
Miami and Tennessee are all seven and
six Baltimore holds the edge they play
Tampa at the Chargers home against
Cleveland if they are to stum
week 17 Sunday Night Football Indy at
Tennessee hmm could be epic yeah could
be good I wanna I know this and the AFC
I like the six teams that are in right
now teams that I would say teams I want
with Baltimore but if Baltimore doesn't
make it I wanted to be the Colts I agree
I do yeah I'm not interested in
Tennessee yeah and I'm not interested in
Miami
I mean Houston if they're the three seed
and they got to go damn we got to play
the Colts game so they're not gonna be
happy about that that's for sure and
imagine in Pittsburgh gets the Chargers
again at home that would be hilarious
till it was a great day for my
season-long bets that I made in Atlantic
City
I have Baltimore over eight and a half
wins I still feel good about them
getting there yeah
I had Miami over seven which you get a
win over the Patriots Campbell I have a
chance to hit that yeah and then Buffalo
under six ooh
Buffalo under six yeah wait they have to
go under six under six wins
what's their what's their remaining
schedule that saved you yesterday that's
what I'm saying I bet for them and I
really should be betting against them
from now on
the Buffalo Bills the rest of the season
and Pat's again right and the Dolphins
Alliance ship in terms of awful fields
Miami New England awful field yeah
Raiders Steelers clearly awful feel with
a field goal kicker sliding New Orleans
Tampa Giants Washington Detroit Arizona
dude it was embarrassing I know in my
Paris I don't know what else to say we
don't have to I just want to point
attention yeah and then the ref
screw-ups
I mentioned the ones in the Chiefs the
no call for Willie Snead the Phantom
call against Crabtree Eagles the opening
kickoff the Goddard offensive pass
interference
cowboy fans were upset about that
roughing the passer call that a lot of
people deemed as a make up call for the
goddard OPI Packers Falcons Joe Philbin
challenges those two catches by Julio
Jones in the beginning neither them were
overturned and I'm telling you both of
them should have been over to yeah I
mean the first one look like yeah it was
not a catch at all and then Bears Rams
the fake punt spot egregiously bad they
had to challenge that if they got Alan
Robinson touchdown
the guy is standing there Allen
Robertson clearly steps out of bound
checks or another guy right I just saw a
lot of traditional media folks yeah
the mic will bonds the Colin Cowherd
saying worst game of referees they miss
Dean Blandino and I don't know it's just
I always go if all those guys are
commenting then I don't think it's
exactly buddy in the NFL knows they're
missing Dean Blandino I mean everybody
really me people around the NFL laugh at
the NFL that they they wouldn't wanted
to save what a few hundred thousand
dollars and not let Dean I mean that's
all it was Fox al bid them the NFL for
the referee guy I mean that's what
happened that's what happened that's all
it I thought Dean was just like it's
time for me to move to media they made
him a good offer if NFL came back and
matched that they think he'd still be
there how about the door cuz my thing is
I never want to be the reactionary fan
right and go man these refs are worse
than normal because it there's always
calls but does it really feel worse than
normal to you yeah there's been a few
times this year that I've certainly felt
like damn yeah they've missed a few here
and there I mean there was more than
just the false start touchdown last week
you know what another game there's a
false started last week when I watched
film I forgot to tell you this your
Carson Wentz touchdown to Golden Tate in
the end zone and the Monday night game
yes it's washing it was a false story
Peters it was a right tackle I think I
think it was late job it was Lena he
falls started oh the same thing I have a
theory that Jason Peters false starts
every play and they just don't ever call
it yeah he makes it close he's he's
trying to get that veteran jump alright
so we've already previewed Minnesota
Seattle and then again that's happening
last night because this comes out
Tuesday you went with who I won with
Seattle me too like twenty seven twenty
something like that I don't remember
exactly what I mean I'm not gonna pick
Minnesota in one of these games until I
see that they have some sort of a run
game like when you're this when you're
that one-sided all the time I guess a
team like Seattle I just have a hard
time thinking you're just gonna sit
there and throw the ball and Wednesday
you're gonna do a deep dive and then
we're gonna preview arguably the best
Thursday night football game of the year
yeah Kansas City Chiefs Los
this charger I should be you don't think
the Chargers are good so it's not that
great of a matchup but I'm gonna I'm
gonna really regret that if Tyree kill
doesn't play oh man it's gonna be pretty
shitty right
I mean if gosh okay yeah real
interesting if the charger somehow
pulled it pulled this off I mean Patrick
mahomes in my fantasy playoffs killer so
hopefully you're listening to this in
Kyle Rudolph caught no passes last night
Odell Rogers needs it we appreciate you
guys for Sims he's out homies Hendrik
says and the lef koe man says holla
holla holla holla holla holla holla
every single game 631 feelin good pizza
homies 631
you